at what point this season do we find out
how he gets back if he gets back from
Hell to earth you find out a lot of
stuff in the first episode actually
about what Lucifer's intentions are okay
so I'll leave it as a tease why can't
you tell me all this earlier only Edie
is on the set of Lucifer as the cast
films a special episode for season 5
final season of Lucifer very exciting I
want to talk about the episode that
you're shooting now because you look
very dapper at the 1940s new are episode
from what yeah what can you tease
welcome to you I can't tease too much I
would say on this episode we take a trip
down memory lane Lucifer we tell a story
that answers the question a lot of fans
have been asking actually which is I
can't tell you that
the lovely thing about this episode is
you see a lot of our regular characters
in a different light okay and that's
what all the costumes are you're talking
about personality what I think
characteristic wise yes up what
characteristics are we gonna see from
you well the thing about Lucifer is that
he's timeless so he's been coming back
and forth to earth all this time so what
I would say about this episode is the
nice thing is that Lucifer seems to be
for a little sometimes from a slightly
different age there's an element to
Lucifer where he seems to be from sort
of the Oscar Wilde or something like
that and to see the other characters
sort of pull back into that style is
quite interesting yeah I suppose you got
a point
where's Chloe at well Chloe's pretty
much non-existent in this episode it's
the alternate universe episode it's not
in black and white so none of us are
playing our characters which is really
really fun well everyone has a
really different take on what they
normally do well I think that'll be
great
the the language to speak the look I
mean the cotton wardrobe hair makeup
they just killed it everyone looks
phenomenal
and I think I'll just get you know I
mean I know they love the show but it's
also fun to see the cast that you love
doing something so different
totally I would imagine yeah I hope they
really like it we are loving it I'm
having I was actually kind of dreading
this episode to be honest because I was
very nervous to kind of go straight into
this one and have a whole new kind of
speak and a whole new walk and all of
these things to work on and I honestly
don't want it to end I'm having so much
fun yeah do you have an accent I do a
little like a slight can you give it a
taste like it's deeper down here and I
go with a little better like this when
you listen to me
this is it this is your big trick is it
fun for you to play something different
than the day-in day-out Ella that we're
so used to yeah I mean I love Ella and I
love that she is a ray of sunshine and I
love that she's a goofball makes people
laugh but to just do something totally
different is like going you know it's
like going to a different place on
vacation this episode is being shot like
them film so it is something that no
other show out of the dozens and dozens
of shows that are out there have ever
done the scope of it and the feel of it
and the style of it is so one-of-a-kind
film classic like you're really you
really do not number cuz you're so
adorable and I'm trying not to look into
your eyes because I feel like you have
the Lucifer thing oh no or you're gonna
make me spill the beans and I'm gonna
get in trouble let's just say that you
are gonna see me in the polar opposite
way you could possibly imagine
like imagine Ella sunshine so you think
well we're going dark we're going we're
going 180 we're going like Ella's here
and it's just gonna be so when you see
who I am in this episode let me just say
the one word I would use is
unrecognizable
that's a great word that's a great to
use actually I really yeah yeah okay is
that yeah that was great
dodged that Lucifer mojo right there
it's people like to tell me things let's
do something about this Thanks how are
the costumes for you outrageous yeah
yeah outrage comfortable now I wouldn't
say it was comfortable
I'd say it's appropriate though okay um
and I think it's gonna be pretty funny
yeah you're gonna see DB as a man a deal
physically playing something that we
haven't
seen on this show yet there is a balance
here that we must maintain the first
thing that I thought when I heard about
this episode was there's gonna be a
musical moment yeah you're probably
right about it yeah how was that
development yeah it was um
it's always fun to film the music stuff
you know we it's been a really sort of
nice element to the show that came in
season one and is just we just sort of
run with it since but the nice thing is
it's not just loose of everything's
these days I heard that it's a duet
mm-hmm can you reveal who I can't Tom
couldn't reveal who but et can it's
Leslie and Brant aka maze is there any
piano stuff isn't it it is well I gotta
get creative of these questions yeah um
piano there will be some piano in there
okay
we
there is a musical moment yeah if you
will how our fans gonna feel when they
watch that do you think oh I think we're
gonna love it there's a musical episode
that we have coming up Oh another one
oh well there's a musical number in this
episode and I think when fans see that
one between two cast members it's going
to take them back and they're really
gonna love it and you want to quickly
ask you about Trisha help they're coming
back is it wrong though is it mum
Charlotte that's I'm just gonna leave it
out there is it mom is it sure the
picture she looked a lot different than
we've seen her on this show if you walk
around everyone looks look how does she
shake things up she's a big player in
the story that we're telling at the
moment that's all I was saying any other
guest stars we can expect
mmm that's it yes maybe you might even
see some people you actually no no no
returning characters that were you maybe
gotta see stuff is here this is so tough
can you give us one hint one hint one
hint
someone is not always known for being an
actor how are you do you know how the
series ends how our fans gonna feel well
I hope they'll feel slightly more like
satisfied in the way that Breaking Bad
in days rather than the Game of Thrones
put in that way so you feel like we're
gonna get the answers that we want yeah
I mean the beautiful thing is that not
you're not always lucky enough to know
that this is your final season right so
to have that you know it's been great
for our writers to be able to relate to
it and you know spend our story properly
oh oh oh you know how it ends I do know
it how it ends I can't lose first of all
this one is the most stunning I okay you
just like look at her eyes and you like
follow your two nice rabbit hole of so
um her and Lucifer I think could have a
mojo documented forever it's true but I
do know how it ends and I will be
totally honest when they told me how it
ends I may have gotten a little bit
emotional and then the first thing I did
was just touch my heart I'm sure there
will be a lot of Kleenexes yeah
especially cuz anyone who's a hopeless
romantic out there you know we have a
very beauty in the beasts love story
going on and ultimately you know it's
it's about love but y'all hoes are gonna
cry or you're gonna cry your little eyes
out and we're gonna rip out your hearts
and we're gonna make you laugh and it'll
be fun it's a wedding
oh I don't know about that you'll just
have to wait and see
[Music]